saying goodbye to a father grandfather
and husband
the family of eric echevarria held a
vigil to honor his life
after he was killed in a car crash
madison kimbrough shows us how they paid
tribute from the memorial site
you know if you're going to drink or get
high whatever you're gonna do dude in
your house like don't drive he took a
a dad from my 14 year old son he took my
husband my
my best friend my life partner my my
everything i don't even know what i'm
gonna do without him
a visual was held for 52 year old eric
echeverria
who died last week after being hit by a
teen driver
that teen 19-year-old zeon collins is
being accused of driving under the
influence
and is facing several other charges my
family is hurting
they're in pain they feel that justice
hasn't been served
and i know it's too soon to speak but
we're hoping that
something does happen tonight friends
and family came out to honor eric's life
flowers balloons and pictures were all
set up along with music playing in the
background
family members and friends spoke briefly
before participating in a two-minute
moment of silence
you know it has taken a little bit for
it to sink in
you know i'm still in denial still in
shock that that he's gone
so we're just setting everything up
making the arrangements for
you know for our service echeveria was
described as a happy man
always smiling joking around with a
heart of gold
he was originally from new york but
spent the last 23 years here in las
vegas
he was an army vet and worked as a
custodian for the clark county school
district
for 18 years madison kimbrough 8 news
now
as for collins he was released with
electronic monitoring and is due back in
court for a status check later this week